all right at least i don't do crystal
meth in the bathroom all night long
just because you can doesn't mean you
should girl you have a little family van
so you want a fight
enough surprise that's my opinion
is a very special place if you enter
those doors something happens
[Music]
why did i just realize that none of us
are no longer on any of our shows
ex-wife's folks
we are destroying this town
i'm very turned on right now do you want
to go to a naked party
[Music]
[Applause]
bye bye peasants when you have to go to
woken up around here i can't get dick
face of an angel mouth of a serpent now
that could
when my bubble bursts i burst back can
you tell that truth a unicorn's gonna
show up birds of a feather flock
together i am not flocking with that
bird
shut up no you shut the [ __ ] up i won't
tell you anything anymore about my
relationship how's that i was on a show
that you're no longer on
i am social distancing from the
i can't go to another hospital with you
it's gonna be a van giant what the [ __ ]
is the mangina don't be a liar i'm gonna
walk away because i'm about to get you
know she doesn't book the lie we are
fighting about stuff i did there's a lot
of conflict going on with eight women
the only conflict is you
what made you think the lady was a
lesbian
her eyebrows
these women are nuts it's like when
girls get their periods together ah that
[ __ ] has salt vicki i want to show you
how to use a library i might have to
paint my pants again
it's the ex-wives club gotta stop
calling people
one rotten apple to spoil the whole
barrel
life is but a dream
you